I wow that would be a very trivial to
will be a kingdom of gigs but everything
same would be I think a very in some
sense it will be a good and a happy amp
and then to my story because you know it
will just prove that nothing can ever
change I actually I take my own argument
seriously and I think that we have to
entertain the possibility that the gigs
will succeed in the many of the projects
you know you look bad to say 15 years
ago and if I told you that you know in
15 years you'll have a technology
company that will manage to scan all of
the world's box and we'll also be
working on asteroid mining you say that
both of those things are insane you
think about it today only one of those
things are the same they have digitized
over the world's box and they about to
start mining the asteroids right so I
mean again I these people like me who
tend to be skeptical of such Ethiopian
schemes we tend to attack them for their
impracticality we say that it's never
going to work what I try to do in this
book was to actually try to take gigs at
their work and try to imagine what would
happen if they succeed because they can
succeed in part because there is a logic
operating in society at the political
level the policy makers wouldn't be
unhappy to outsource politics to Silicon
Valley entirely because now they run all
the platforms through which you can
provide the right incentives and right
not just for the people so you carry a
mobile phone why not reward dubis points
for showing up at the voting booth right
if you can reward people for voting why
not do it through facebook where they
can accumulate points for throwing out
the garbage for voting for everything
that previously they did because they
thought it was the right thing to do now
that will do it because they're only
point I'm competing with their friends
right and this is what I find so
terrifying because there is this very
bizarre alliance between world-changing
gigs on the one hand in policy makers
who only care about outcomes they no
longer care about how does outcomes
arrive that they have stripped politics
of all meaning all they want is to get
people to do the right thing they don't
care why they do it and what I'm trying
to recover in the book and to me
they're explicit case for is that we
should do the right thing for the right
reasons if you don't do the right thing
for the right reasons you might
essentially end up with a very
impoverished view of society of all
direction of the human condition once
you start rewarding people with points
for engaging in environmentally friendly
behavior you have to understand that you
have to reward the response for anything
they will not pick up in a piece of
paper lying on the ground and throw it
into the garbage can unless they're in
points for that right there is this
totalizing logic which can easily spread
everywhere we can partly see it with
this part of the market logic so in some
sense what I'm talking about here is
also an extension of the growing
marketization if you will off our
political and social world but again I
just to reiterate I do think that there
is a very good chance that the geeks
will succeed I do think that a lot about
political institutions will change I do
think that a lot of the decisions that
essentially have to be decided in a
political democratic fashion will be
outsourced to unaccountable private
corporations in Silicon Valley it's not
to me a given that the right way to
solve climate change is to inform people
about how much electricity they are
consuming it might be one of the many
possible solutions but other thing we
need to do something on a much larger
scale and we need to engage in political
reform what would be tempting for the
policymakers to do is to just rely on
say google to send a reminder you just
remind you every day how much entities
you're consuming how many miles you have
walked right to tell you how many months
you have walked in a given day as a way
of fighting obesity it's not gonna work
because a lot of people can't afford
cars they can't afford healthy food they
can't afford access to farmers markets
they live in places where there is no
public transportation and they have to
drive a car instead of walking all of
those a big structural macro level
problems which will not be able to solve
only forget individual citizens to track
how many calories they consume how many
miles they have worked in an hour in a
day and it's this shift for macro level
political projects to micro level
consumer-driven part
that I find so terrifying because again
it's just not going to solve the
problems that kind of facing which many
of them exist so I'm not saying that all
the problems gets a time to solve a
imaginary many of the problems are real
existing problems climate change would
be one in our house would be another it
just that the means by which they go
about solving them they believe that
those means entirely and problematic and
obvious and unpolitical and I think that
they're not little obvious and their
political and then they may actually be
worse than more productive ways my final
question you were all in town with
politician Marie Stewart and was talking
about the big gap between the individual
and the big ideas and he felt that
somewhere in the middle was politics
with a sort of local roots and do you
agree with that and how technology be
used in a positive sense to reinforce
this sort of middle ground mmm um there
is certainly a certain disconnect but
when they language the grand big
ambitious macro level language of
politics that a lot of our thinking and
policy debates and newspaper debates and
public debates operate and the real
experience of democracy or lag that off
by ordinary citizens you know it's very
hard for people who go about in the
daily life to relate to a problem such
as climate change because in part they
don't see the consequences until they
hit by a hurricane likes and a so now in
America suddenly that is back on the
agenda and people start discussing yet
but that only happened because of
national disaster for me a very big and
important question is how can you make
again in the context of technology but
that also brings us political questions
how can you make the consequences of
technology use more visible during the
use itself so how is it that our
designers consumer designers industrial
designers have built our smart homes in
a way to hide the consequences of all
the devices where user
why is it that we discover how much your
ethnicity we are consuming at the end of
the month and they still have no idea
how to exist the system in our country
operates why as a modern society we have
chosen to hide away from the
consequences of our actions right so in
a sense and you can partly maybe make a
similar argument about politics but here
I think there is also a danger of trying
to make politics with transparent I do
think that politicians need some space
in which to believe I think politicians
need some space to think about issues
and to potentially reject the populace
pressure that is often exerted on them
and that pressure is even easier to
exert now because everyone has some kind
of a tool platform the lobby and very
often conventional lobbying has
reinvented itself as grassroot
initiatives so you have the Tea Party
presenting itself as a grassroot
initiative in America well in fact you
have the Koch brothers the one of the
richest people in America funding its
causes and promoting the agenda that the
Koch brothers have been promoting for 30
years when we talk about the Tea Party
we suddenly see it as a grassroot this
Angeles initiative well in fact it isn't
right so for me the big question is on
the political level I mean in a sense
everything is political so our use of
energy is political in that sense we
need to figure out a way in which to
disrupt things that we take for granted
in our life and in that sense you can
actually delegate some of the political
decisions or not just delegate because
currently those decisions no matter
though but you can politicize many of
the things that we take for granted
through design for me it's how actually
and the book the book I've just finished
it's trying to find a way to build what
I call adversarial design right how can
you build devices that when they're
plugged into your vole in a standby mode
you'll not just sit there idly waiting
and totally wreck enact them but they
will start twisting that they were in
pain right why is it not an obvious
design decision
to sensitize you to how much energy
you're consuming right why can't you
build you know a radio which suddenly
starts misfunctioning if you enter part
of your house where you have most
electricity consumption right again
there are all sorts of disruptions you
could introduce into a built environment
to make things that you take for granted
suddenly look political and force you to
think about complex socio-technical
systems that around in your daily life
and we have I think hidden ourselves
from those consequences because we have
thought that what is political is to be
defined by politicians whom the elect to
represent us and they will set the
parameters or what towns is important
what doesn't talk is important and I
think that model we see in the longer
works and this is where I think
designers and engineers take on an
outsized role because instead of
building things that are highly
functional and it allow us to continue
then sustainable project we are
currently on they can actually sensitize
us to the consequences of those projects
and to make us think and reflect on the
big socio-technical systems that they
all part of and unless that happens I
don't think it's realistic to expect
that politics as such as a formal
process will help us uncover the
problems that need to be sold